there seems to be a bit of a tradition
of making a special video when your
YouTube channel passes and million
subscribers it is weighty now I was a
bit slow making mine because well you're
about to see why essentially I wanted to
show how big a million is a way to kind
of visualize it this is where the idea
of printing PI to a million digits came
from of course a million digits of pi
have been known for a long time you can
see them on the internet even by a book
of them but I wanted to print it like a
conventional number left to right on a
single piece of paper I had no idea what
this would look like or even how big it
would need to be so after a few emails
and phone calls and this is cutting a
long story short I ended up travelling
to Denmark to a printing company called
HSA systems these people were amazing
and it seems no job was too big for them
Here I am with a guy called Torben who
was an absolute star and is the guy who
really made this happen from a technical
standpoint for various reasons including
the fact it's a monospace font we
decided to print pie in courier new the
point size we chose was 8 this means
each digit was 40 pixels wide one pixel
is one six hundredth of an inch so each
digit was a fifteenth of an inch across
now this meant our million decimal
places or a million and two if you count
the three and the decimal point would be
one point zero five miles long nearly
1,700 meters how is that for some
serious numberphile action here we are
doing a test print run and as you can
see it's on white paper
now numberphile fans will know that we
love brown paper and two reels of
special brown paper had been donated by
a UK company called Millington
but it had not arrived it was due to
arrive at just Padian so it looked like
we might resort to using the white paper
which was easier to get our hands on it
was kind of like the backup but at the
last minute like the last minute the
brown paper arrived you're a hero
there we go here is being mounted and
we're about to start printing by the way
this guy is humic partland he's HSAs man
in the UK he's with me here in Denmark
and he's the real reason the whole
project really succeeded you'll see more
of him later
I have to say it was amazing how
smoothly the whole thing went and a
print run took about 48 and a half
minutes
it turns out the whole thing hinged on
this wheel the encoder which measures
how far along the paper we are now it's
just three one hundredths of a
millimeter of being a perfect circle
which means I'm told our spacing was
pretty good and I must say I do find it
lovely how circles and of course pie
were used and were so instrumental in
our printing of pie now in addition to
just the numbers the decimal places of
pie
we included markers all the way along to
count the decimal places there was a
marker every 10 digits this was so we'd
be able to find parts of pie more easily
when the time came okay so looking for
216 1/8 hmm we also had a marker every
yard along the paper to give us an idea
of distance traveled
now I would have preferred meters being
bit of a metric man myself but for
complicated reasons it was hard to make
this synchronize it all relates to the
fact that technology we were using to
print with is in dots per inch it made
our chunks of pie more easily divided
into imperial units we had a lot of
problems when we tried to do it in
meters now here's a quick interview with
Jasper he's the boss at HSA and another
man we owe a huge debt to well we do not
only do one type of printer right we do
a lot of different printers and printer
controllers that were manufactured
nology but also saw technology out of
England Canberra England we do both
software we do the printed circuit
boards we do the print heads to control
us everything right we do a lot of
number printing and that could be for
example lottery it could be pin numbers
it could be a unique identifier for
products for example within the the food
industry right well they would may
require a unique identification of a
certain product and we would either
generate the number from straight from
our software or we would load a database
and then print the numbers from the
database well numbers mathematics is
very much a big part of our day right
calculating BP eyes and pulses per
rotation and what have we not so and
I'll say we're not the ones doing the
heart mathematics that's the the guys in
Copenhagen who who do the software and
also the core the core of the software
doing they're the heart mathematics and
namely calculating how to get a drop out
of the printhead at the right time right
size etc etc so but yes
mathematics is a very big part of our
our working day that's for sure tell me
what you know about pie
what I know about pie okay well it's not
a math test there's not a math you case
they know the numbers do I have to wear
flip-flops and a white sheet now or well
oh you've never written have you ever
had to print out pie before no never no
we're never done that we do you we do
make use of pie of course in our
everyday work that's for sure and we
know a bit about pie because we have to
do a bit of calculations when it comes
to
our tooling machines etc you've got
certain things everywhere we could
service everywhere yeah and of course we
use pile art but there we have never
done 1 million bits it's pi before on a
printing machine so that's quite
exciting is have you done any number to
a million digits or am I your first well
you're the first where we've done a
million dentists that's for sure
there you go to over a big piece of pie
there so after printing a real what next
well wrap it up of course and then print
another one we figured this would be a
handy Backup if something went wrong if
you're interested the second rail was
never actually used and it's still in my
office if you're some wealthy math
enthusiast you can even make me an offer
if you like I warn you postage will not
be cheap now I also still have the HP
cartridges we use to print the whole
thing amazingly we used only 20% of a
cartridge just over eight milliliters of
ink this is what eight milliliters of
ink looks like or 194 million tiny drops
from the printhead the people at HP a
brightly proud of what their stuff can
do it's called thermal inkjet technology
they were also super excited when they
found out about the PI project and later
they helped me cover some of the
production costs this was really
generous of them and I'm very grateful
so anyway two rolls were printed and
then it was back to the UK for me and
the rolls were posted not far behind
here they are when they arrived at my
house next was arranging a way to unroll
the paper now after a wild goose chase
and calling several Air Force bases I
was able to hire the former RAF base at
Bruntingthorpe at in Leicester shear in
England which is now used as a car
testing track an aviation museum they've
got all these Cold War jets there I have
to say if you like planes or exotic
sports cars this is a place that will
blow your mind now a section of their
two-mile runway was sectioned off so we
could do our thing it turns out no one
else was using the facility that day we
had the whole runway to ourselves but we
were there with no real sense of how
difficult this might be no idea how a
mile of paper could be effectively
unrolled but that man who together with
a chap named John Kenny devised an
ingenious contraption here are the
designs they made and here is the real
thing after it was made by John
like and um my fingers in the other end
now I've got to admit I had a mild heart
attack here thinking the paper wouldn't
fit mm not sure about that but it got on
and we were able to start number for
regular and pie enthusiast Matt Parker
came along to be our tour guide I should
probably thank him for giving up a whole
day but I think he enjoyed himself far
too much as it is this is very exciting
okay now the unrolling was okay and even
the rain was tolerable though a nuisance
but the biggest problem was wind
you
the wind was mercifully very light to
this day but it still played havoc with
the paper luckily I'd brought some bags
of sand we were able to use this to
weigh down the paper but the sand was
running out fast we sent for more cones
which was stored elsewhere on the site
they helped
and then I went for a drive to the end
of the runway and found something else
that helped these cone bases which were
nice and heavy but not too tall so we
could stack them in the back of the car
now while the runway crew worked really
hard on the rollout Matt and I spent
some time further back recording PI
facts now much of this was cut from the
main video that's just how things go we
needed to keep the video short but now
I'm going to show you more of them enjoy
these and when they're finished I'll
tell you more about how the day ended pi
what a number ABS
it's unparalleled in mathematics and as
we all know the digits never end they
just keep on going forever and ever
which is incredible and you can download
huge numbers of these digits and some
people insanely will print off up tens
of thousands of them and make like a
poster not Brady no at numberphile he
has printed off a million digits so this
is the beginning and this is a mile so
you can see they're unraveling it
further up there there is one mile of a
continuous piece of paper alright so it
is raining a little bit but that's fine
that's a good thing wet pie doesn't
change if it gets wet so we're going to
begin our exploration and I Wow I know
who knew its moisture invariants so here
I marked the first 10 decimal places
that only use three different digits
okay here we've got one five six five
five one five six five six six six one
one one and that is a run of 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
which only uses three different digits
so think I mean so here at number file
we're answering all the questions that
no one's ever asked
ok so we've come a fair way where are we
now we're up to a hundred and twenty-one
yards so we're at 11 squared yards and
we're working away along and I mean
famously people try and memorize pi and
so I've got it down to you know the
first couple of digits and one of our
support vehicles is coming up ready you
might want to pop out of the way that's
not he stopt he's doing out
89,000
if you take the alphabet so a becomes 1
b becomes 2 c becomes 3 and so on
you can turn words into letter so my
name is matt ma TT m as the 13th letter
of the alphabet a is the first teeth of
twentieth so I'll be looking for 1 3 0 1
2 0 2 0 for 13 1 20 20 and you can fold
on past it
let's let 0 2 that is a put up here that
is a B work my way backwards so before
that is a 12 that is al before that is
an 8 that's an H before that is a 15
that's an O 4 that is a 23
it's a W before that is a 5 that's an E
before that is an 8 is another H I'm
writing in a panel for it as a 14 as a n
before that is a 25 is a why and before
that is a 60-watt said ok so that's not
so that there that is nine digits for
nine letters so it's 18 digits and it
says yeah you are hollow that's not a
word
well it's a word starting it's not a
word that makes sense like it's not a
word in the English language but it is a
string of letters and actually if you
want the longest word that makes sense
it's over here somewhere we can go and
find that current that is the first five
letter word which is actually a
recognised word in the English language
kirat was a French landscape and
portrait painter as well as a printmaker
in itching there you go or car oh I
guess it should be if we go all up to
three hundred and eighty thousand two
hundred fifty three we come across greed
but greed is in greedy greedy re d
as in a leader in the development and
production of lightweight ultra
high-strength cast ductile iron
components so it's a company called
greed after that's brawl at four hundred
and sixty six thousand five hundred
seventy four digits rule is a French
singer actor and professional poker
player and then later on khufu which is
a 2004 Indian film and then at the very
end about nine digits before we finish
is via F J which I think looks a little
bit like via Fiji not impressive I'll
bet you look underwhelmed to be honest a
lot of people think that any word if you
look far enough will be in PI somewhere
and so far all the ones we've checked
are but it's not guaranteed so PI we
think it's something called a normal
number however we don't know for certain
if it is a normal number we just think
it is and if it is a normal number it
means any string of digits as equally
likely or appears with equal frequency
compared to any other string of digits
so length and so if what is normal
that's true but we don't know so
whenever someone says any word or any
expression or any phrase you ever come
up with it somewhere in PI you can say R
we think so but we don't know for
certain so the vast majority of real
numbers are normal but it's very hard if
you're given a number as an example to
prove that that number someone's given
you is definitely normal in fact we've
done that so far for no numbers no
naturally like no numbers we've just
found have since been proven to be
normal
but we know that they're all out that we
know most numbers are normal in fact the
complete works of William Shakespeare
appears in more numbers than it doesn't
so every so people say that PI it's not
that exciting when it comes to PI in
fact my name Matt afisma appears on the
first billion digits of root two it's in
the first billion digits of eight I've
checked all these and it's in the first
billion digits I hate to say it of the
golden ratio so in fact if you pick the
number at random odds are my name will
be in there probably in the first
billion digits if you actually do want
to find your name in a normal number it
was a number called the Copeland
oddish number and what copeland and a
dish did was they got the number they
started zero point and then it's all the
prime numbers in a row
so it goes 2 and then 3 and then 5 and
then 7 then 1 and 1 for 11 and you just
put them in there base 10 form in there
that number is proven to be normal
because it was generated to be normal
and so if you have the Copeland air dish
constant in there somewhere is
guaranteed to be the works of
Shakespeare your name what you're going
to have for lunch tomorrow anyway you
want to encode it is in there somewhere
I think it's also got the complete list
of everything you're not going to have
for lunch tomorrow so it's not very
predictive pie will never fall into a
recurring pattern so so no point will
have become recurring but you may have
incredibly long strings like that
infinitely long no peril you're going to
very very long strings our digits or
predictable bits or I mean 3.141592 it
may appear in there somewhere else so
any chunk I look at here that's going to
appear somewhere else but not in any
kind of predictable fashion pi is what's
called a transcendental number which
means you can't write it down in a nice
neat equation so you kind of equations
for PI I mean somehow we calculated the
first million digits but that's with an
equation where you always need more and
more terms to get more and more accuracy
if you have a polynomial with the
coefficients that behave themselves
you're never going to get PI out as an
answer and there's there's no repeating
finite way you can write down pi now
while we've been talking I've noticed
that the people putting down PI have
gotten substantially smaller in fact
they're probably most of the way to the
horizon at this point so we should go we
should go catch them up if I label that
you'll see here one seven six four five
one of the digits three one four one
five nine there it is three one four one
one five nine that is the longest bit of
the beginning of pi in pi in the first
million decimal places so there it is
three one four exhausted I shouldn't
have run this far it was really
interesting right people say PI is
random and this is a million
random digit so a lot of what we've been
finding things you'd expect anywhere in
randomness but I've never seen this bit
of paper before in my life right you
said Matt look up some things in PI I
just did it at home on my computer but
yet when I come here to a million random
digits I knew exactly where that was
going to be I came along there it is PI
yes it's random but predictable and we
can calculate it and it's always the
same and that's amazing how you lie down
yes there it is
half a million so that there is the half
a million digits of pi if you don't
include the three at the beginning the
half million digit is a two so is right
there too far far in the distance a
dedicated team of people with a trolley
with the PI like real on it gradually
unrolling and I mean it's hard to tell
how much is left if only we had some
kind of mathematical constant to
calculate how much paper is going around
it as it unravels who knows but they're
doing an amazing job and they're putting
it down faster than we're talking about
it which I find a little bit disturbing
because they're all business like
they've got a Wailord machine cones
moving things going down whereas we're
just nerding out on hey look three
sevens and then they're disappearing off
into the gist
we probably should either go and help
them or make them some tea
you can see I'll underline it there it's
a bit small that's eleven thousand four
hundred and ninety two okay so before
that if I if we'd stop putting the pie
out here right if there had been the end
of the piece of paper every number from
one up to eleven thousand four hundred
and ninety one is in there somewhere so
eleven thousand five hundred ninety one
is the biggest number for which every
smaller number is somewhere in there and
then suddenly eleven thousand 492
appears and now you think we'll you know
where's eleven thousand four hundred and
ninety three we've already had it in
fact we've already had loads
the next number well in the entire mile
of pie as of now the biggest number for
which every number smaller than is in
here somewhere is fourteen thousand five
hundred and twenty-two there is no
fourteen thousand five hundred and
twenty three anywhere in the first
million digits of pi it is the smallest
number which is not in the first million
decimal places I checked I I think I've
got those digits right I assure you if
I've gotten them wrong people will
believe a comment under the video okay
so we've found eleven thousand 100 or
ninety two the next number up brady is a
bit of a special treat for you so we
need to go up into the it's on the order
of eight hundred and fifty seven
thousand one hundred and eighty seven
from memory let's so quote me on that
let's find it okay we've actually got a
drone here filming is actually amazing
and as you can hear they're incredibly
subtle
you wouldn't know you've been killed by
a drone right now one technology man
five million six hundred and thirteen
thousand four hundred and eighty seven
recognize that I feel like I should you
should that is the biggest Brady number
that appears in the first one million
decimal places of pie so there you are
that's I honestly that seven digits long
I was I was astounded when I saw that
appear so
mean there's every four digit numbers in
here somewhere
most of the five digit numbers
reasonable chances on six once you hit
seven starts getting a lot less likely
and so I thought you know I'll just
check the Brady numbers and sure enough
there it is I mean we're not that far
from the end now you can see our crew
just down there I think they've almost
finished
and so we're what we're eighty five
point seven percent of the way through
the first million digits sure enough
seven digit Brady no I hate I to
encourage the ongoing discussion and
research into Brady numbers but I'm very
impressed there's one just there so the
last little bit it took three hours to
unroll the first half mile of paper but
then the team got on a roll with the new
cones and the cone bases and a better
system and better weather the next half
mile was all done within about an hour
you were due to the one hours now I did
a bit of editing of the video finale
when you watch the main film but here's
how it played out without me interfering
with the editing
okay we're four hours into this and we
are nearly at a million digits so
they've been coming out at a rate of a
quarter of a million digits an hour
which is approximately four thousand one
hundred and sixty seven digits a minute
and we're we're almost there so I mean
you guys have done the hard work you
want to whine off the last of this and a
million digits is there all right so if
we so if we just take that off there all
right so that is there is what it's a
one in case you're wondering so we
just tip it towards me of it yep it's a
one so there you go we have just I mean
I think a token round of applause well
done guys we have just hit that is the
quietest round of applause I've heard in
my life so too tired to applaud so I
mean that is absolutely amazing I'm
Brady you have just set the world record
for the most digits of pi ever printed
out on paper although by simply adding a
three I will now have the world record
for the most digits of three oh is it a
nine or a seven guys two digits is good
enough so I've now got the world record
for a million in two decimal places of
Pi listed out so that is absolutely
fantastic and now the very quick process
of rolling it all back up again before
an airplane lands cool all right I
should also thank James Hennessy and
Edie field and for doing much of the
camera work I was very much focused on
the stuff with Matt but most of the
great shots you see in the final film
came from James and Ed the drone shots I
mean they were just amazing I think I
could look at these all day
here I've marked the start and the end
point of our 1.05 miles
finally it was time to clear up and I'm
a little point one of the pissed end of
the way through before we started they'd
been plans to reroll the paper back onto
its reel but that was clearly misguided
and besides the rain and wind had
wreaked havoc finally weakening and then
starting to rip some sections of paper
so I sent out two of my helpers Josh and
Jacob to salvage some of the best paper
snippets I still have these ones as
souvenirs includes the start and the
finish of course some other people there
like Josh Jacob and even Matt I think
also snipped out their birthdays where
they could find them within pi the rest
of the paper was simply collected
chopped up screwed into giant bowls and
sent to that recycling bin in the sky
and with that the job was done now I
have to say the whole task was probably
much harder than expected but also more
rewarding and driving around on a runway
is awesome
the whole thing wouldn't have been
possible without these people I think if
the team was any smaller on the day we
may well have failed everyone really
chipped in and thank you to all of them
and thank you to you for watching this
and watching all the videos here on
numberphile hopefully you're among our
million subscribers and will continue to
be for years to come
you
okay you're gonna start seeing sand that
is effectively ballast paperweight
you
Oh